with the rise of use cases such as chat
Bots virtual assistants and increasing
accessibility applications using
automatic speech recognition or ASR are
becoming more and more popular
in this video we're going to be talking
about automated speech recognition on
Google cloud with our very own
speech-to-text API
pre-trained models are great for generic
broad use cases but as you start to get
into specifics certain nuances with
domain-specific knowledge and proper
nouns are not always captured by out of
the box models hi everyone I'm Anu Shri
vastava and in this video I'll walk
through how you can boost ASR accuracy
without having to train your own custom
model
we'll be using the speech to text API
which allows you to accurately convert
audio to text
some of the highlights of the service
are multi-speaker detection if you have
a recording of several people conversing
streaming speech recognition profanity
filtering and support for over 125
languages fun fact it's available
on-prem as well to start let's run a
sample with the API to see how it works
here in my notebook I have a code sample
set up that will transcribe the audio
then print out the results
first I import the client library and
create a client to call the API from
I grab the sample audio file which is
stored in Google Cloud Storage from the
bucket URI let's set a few configuration
variables and call the API
let me play you the sample audio file hi
everyone my name is Anu I live in New
York and I work at Google Cloud
now I'll run it in my notebook and we
have the transcription now that we have
a transcription how do I know the
quality of the output what if I need to
automate bulk transcripts for a business
critical need here is where we need to
Define speech accuracy this is
especially important once we start
working with audio transcription at
scale
one standard to do this is called word
error rate often abbreviated as wer and
this is a formula word error rate
measures the percentage of incorrect
transcriptions in the entire set so this
means that the lower the word error rate
the more accurate the system
word error rate is a combination of
three types of transcription errors
which can occur
first we have substitution errors words
that are present and the hypothesis and
ground truth but not transcribed
correctly
then deletion errors words that are
missing from the hypothesis but present
in the ground truth then we have
insertion error words present in the
hypothesis transcript that are not
present in the ground truth aka the
correct answer as defined by us
when we're doing this at scale there
could be several imperfections in our
transcription which is why we have some
handy tips and tools to help you improve
accuracy
so customize the model to your domain by
providing contextual information so
let's say you are creating a bot that
allows people to order pizza so you
might want to increase the probability
that words like pepperoni olives and
mozzarella are recognized
then tweaking the weights to address
specific word phrase issues so say
you're trying to recognize proper nouns
or rare words or even made up words it's
unlikely that these will be transcribed
correctly initially so biasing towards
them can fix individual terms
using context bias towards specific
types of information or words so let's
say we have an ivr telephone system and
you have just asked someone for their
order number you can buy it specifically
towards an alphanumeric entry let's
check this out in my notebook so here I
have some code that pulls a longer
recording of me talking about my
favorite restaurants nearby so I've
recorded this and uploaded this to a
Google Cloud Storage bucket let me play
the audio sample for you
hey everyone my name is Anu and I live
in New York City my favorite restaurant
is Estella it's on Houston Street in the
Lower East Side neighborhood which we
like to call Les I also love Cuisines
from around the world such as at places
like Sichuan Mountain House and balad
here we will run the sample through the
API
then we implemented a helper to
calculate and display the wer for us
in this sample we actually have the
ground truth or the transcript for our
accuracy calculation written out up here
let's see how we did
pretty good but I think we can boost the
accuracy and lower the word error rate
how can we lower the word error rate
well we can do this by using the speech
adaptation API the speech adaptation API
allows users to pass phrases and
Associated weights directly to the
speech API
these phrases can be changed with every
request and allow for both quick
iteration and on-the-fly adaptation all
you have to do is include the terms and
the request itself as part of the
recognition config
here's an example of what a simple
adaptation would look like
how should you form your adaptations
what are the right terms to provide
there are a few things to consider first
what am I doing with this transcript is
there a downstream system that will be
sensitive to particular words or phrases
these words should get a bias towards
them
are there rare or proper nouns these
should also get a bias boost
what contextual info can I use do you
know what words someone might say or
what they said in the past these can be
biased towards to help increase accuracy
even on commonly occurring words if you
are sure they will be present
do you have strong or weak context you
can bias heavily with strong context if
you are sure the user is about to
mention some specific words
you should buy us less if you have weak
context meaning you know that words will
occur but not exactly when or where
let's go back into our demo sample we're
talking about restaurants and we have
some proper nouns for the locations so
let's try Computing the wer score again
with these boosted phrases voila we were
able to get the word error rate down
from our previous score with a longer
transcript you can keep iterating on
this to fine-tune your results
there you go here's one way you can
boost your accuracy on pre-trained
models without having to build a model
from scratch we hope this was useful and
we can't wait to see what you do with
the speech to text API thanks for
joining and check out the lab link below
to try boosting speech accuracy yourself
[Music]